new music Friday Justin Bruno Kendrick
how they all stack up plus I'm taking
you guys inside Sunday's Golden Globes
hello my people it is the end of the
first week of the new year and we've
made it to our favorite day of the week
new music Friday and clearly 2018 is not
playing around because we have been
blessed with a lot of fresh tracks
beginning with Justin Timberlake
he brought sexy back in 2006 he was
dapper in his suit and tie in 2013 and
now justin is funky futuristic and
filthy like never before
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and now you know why it's called filthy
it's the first single of JT's fifth
studio album which drops February 2nd
now in the video Justin channels Steve
Jobs unveils his latest creation a
dancing robot and said robot gets a
little freaky you can't unsee that in
Twitter blew up with some harsh
criticism over the song literally I
started searching for Justin Timberlake
and the second most searched term on
Twitter was Justin Timberlake trash
wait harsh tie alright I don't hate him
but I will say I was not expecting this
funky futuristic thing considering the
album's title is man of the woods and
the initial promo showed a down-to-earth
Justin and the great outdoors so color
us confuse Justin now the rest of the
album looks like it sticks to theme
though Justin shared the tracklist which
reveals collabs with Alicia Keys and
Chris Stapleton and songs like flannel
and breeze off the pond ok is this is a
love letter to Ron Swanson
alright anyway I will say Justin's got
my attention and I do want to know what
you guys think in the meantime the new
album drops two days before you performs
at the Super Bowl
now Timberlake looked ahead to the
future in filthy but Bruno Mars threw it
back in his colorful music video for
finesse with cardi B - big shout-out to
the classic comedy show and living color
and it is filling my 90s kid heart with
so much nostalgia
[Music]
come on how can you not love that et
learned it was shot in one day in LA and
Bruno had the in living color set built
from speck any even tweeted creator
Keenan Ivory Wayans a very special thank
you
now the combo of Bruno the throwback
King and cardi B wraps new Queen I mean
you can't go wrong
you guys agree let me know all right
giving them a run for their money though
is kendrick lamar and scissor
he's raps heavy hit maker and she is
music's next big thing earning the most
grammy nominations this year of any
female artist they've teamed up for
their first single off the Black Panther
soundtrack which Kendrick is producing
there's no video yet but take a listen
to their track all the stars
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now as always Kendrick raps so well on
that and scissor delivers a catchy hook
but anyone else feeling this is a bit
conservative for these two obviously
this is for a big blockbuster movie but
what we loved about Kendrick stuff
especially damn and what has made Sizzix
stand out is their personalities and I'm
just wondering where they are
I don't know I'm down to be convinced
though so you guys let me know Justin
Bruno and cardi or Kendrick and scissor
who was your favorite new track this
week we've got to pull up now on the
community tab and finally this Sunday is
the 75th Golden Globe Awards one of the
only few award shows where stars from
movies and TV are packed in like
sardines and serve food and endless
champagne as I found out it's about to
be the biggest and best show yet things
are happening so quickly there's more
stars on that stage than ever before hey
guys now I know what you're thinking two
suits in one week well it's just that
time of year it is award season and I'm
here at the Beverly Hilton the home of
the Golden Globe Awards to give you guys
an exclusive sneak peek of what we can
expect from Sunday's award show now from
New Year's to Golden Globes the
champagne is still flowing apparently
the champagne never runs out we have 125
cases of these magnums for the Golden
Globes we have a 1500 minimo wets for
the red carpet if they want 500
signature cocktails made with the
champagne as well so it should never run
out whether it's New Year's or the
Golden Globes actress and lifestyle
expert Jamie Chung has created a
signature cocktail for the 75th annual
Golden Globes Awards is called moet 75
it's tequila honey
blood orange juice and of course more
with the Shawn dawn and each of the
celebrities will be enjoying it inside
the ballroom after they leave the red
carpet about to go leave this interview
go find that because that's 5 o'clock
somewhere
it's amazing the cocktail is good even
at 10 in the morning so as Golden Globe
ambassador you might have one of the
hardest gigs in this ballroom how you
feeling about are you feeling any nerves
some nerves about more than anything I'm
just excited for the big night fun night
right of course you've been by your dad
cypher so many events like this how
excited is he to kind of pay it forward
and now it'd be here to support you he
so excited and he's presenting so I'm
gonna get to share the stage with him
for a minute and that's gonna be so
wonderful for both of us so how are
preps going for you I mean are you
trying to breaking your shoes now but
since you're gonna have to be walking
back and forth across the stage I found
some pretty comfortable shoes and
they're very stylish so I'm excited for
that should be a good time you guys so
make sure you stick with et online.com
for all the Golden Globes goodness on
Sunday then I'll be live on twitter at
ET now and here on e t--'s youtube
channel for a full recap after the
awards show ere so come watch me all
right you guys love you have a good
weekend got a good one on got it going
on
you